FIRST THINGS FIRST, THOUGH.
HEAVY IN OUR HEARTS AND MINDS
ARE THE EVENTS OF SOUTH
CAROLINA, BUT THERE WAS
HOPEFUL NEWS.
GOV. NIKKI HALEY FINALLY CAME
FORWARD AND ADDRESSED THE FACT
THAT THE CONFEDERATE FLAG IS
STILL HANGING IN FRONT OF THE
SOUTH CAROLINA STATE CAPITAL.
>> TODAY WE'RE HERE AT A
MOMENT OF UNITY IN OUR STATE
WITHOUT ILL WILL TO SAY IT'S
TIME TO MOVE THE FLAG FROM THE
CAPITAL GROUNDS.
>> YES.
[
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
GOOD FOR YOU, SOUTH CAROLINA. UP
HERE, NIKKI!
BUT SERIOUSLY, I MEAN, WHO
COULD HAVE BEEN AGAINST THIS,
RIGHT?
ESPECIALLY IN THE LIGHT OF THE
INCIDENT THAT JUST HAPPENED,
AND PARTICULARLY IN 2015.
ANYBODY RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
TRYING TO GET REPUBLICAN
VOTES?
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT THEY SAID
THIS WEEKEND.
>> I STILL FEEL IT'S NOT AN
ISSUE FOR A PERSON RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
>> MARCO RUBIO TELLING REPORTERS
THE PEOPLE OF SOUTH CAROLINA
WILL MAKE THE DECISION
>> THAT'S A DECISION FOR THE
PEOPLE OF SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> THIS IS A DECISION THAT
NEEDS TO BE MADE IN SOUTH
CAROLINA.
>> STATES RIGHTS IS A CLASSIC
PRESIDENTIAL  CANDIDATE COP OUT.
WHEN YOU ASK ME IF THE SKY IS
BLUE, THAT'S A QUESTION BEST
LEFT TO THE STATE.
>> HOW DO I KNOW WHAT YOU
WOULD DO WITH THE FLAG?
I'M NOT A FLAG SCIENTIST.
I WANT TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, NOT PRESIDENT
OF FLAGS.
I REJECT YOUR QUESTION.
>> I WANT TO KNOW, ARE YOU
TAKING
THIS DOWN TOMORROW.
ARE YOU TAKING IT DOWN
TONIGHT?
BECAUSE I CAN COME OVER WITH A
FLASHLIGHT.
>> THE U.S. FLAG WAS HALF
STAFF, BUT THE  REBEL FLAG
REMAINED HIGH,
PADLOCKED AND UNTOUCHABLE
WITHOUT AN  OVERRIDE BY 2/3 OF
THE  STATE LEGISLATURE.
>> PADLOCKED? WELL, OKAY, NO
PROBLEM.
YOU GET THAT TWO THIRDS, BLAH,
BLAH, BLAH, AND I'LL GET THE
KEY.
I HAVE ONE OF THOSE.
RIGHT HERE.
THIS WILL OPEN ANY PAD LOCK OR
NON-PAD LOCK OR MAXIMUM
SECURITY PRISON IN UPSTATE NEW
YORK.
OOPS.
PERHAPS I SAID TOO MUCH
ANYHOW, THE POINT IS, YOU'RE
TAKING THAT FLAG DOWN, RIGHT?
>> AS GOVERNOR, I HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO CALL THEM BACK
INTO SESSION UNDER
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES.
I'VE INDICATED TO THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE, THAT IF THEY
DO NOT TAKE MEASURES THIS
SUMMER, I WILL USE THAT
AUTHORITY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THE LEGISLATURE REMOVING THE
FLAG FROM THE STATEHOUSE
GROUNDS:
>> SO YOU WANT THEM TO COME
BACK TO DEBATE TAKING IT DOWN,
BUT THERE'S A CHANCE THAT THEY
WON'T.
SO YOU SAY HEY, GUYS, YOU
BETTER COME BACK AND TALK
ABOUT THIS.
SOUTH CAROLINA -- (BLEEP)
I'M JUST GOING TO HAVE TO
RETRACT MY UP HERE.
LET ME GIVE YOU UNSOLICITED
ADVICE.
HOW ABOUT JUST TAKE THE DAMN
FLAG DOWN RIGHT NOW
[ APPLAUSE ]
HEAR ME OUT.
AND THEN YOU CAN DEBATE PUTTING
IT BACK UP.
[ APPLAUSE ]
HOW ABOUT THAT?
NOW I KNOW AS GOVERNOR, YOU
HAVE TO FOLLOW THE RULES, BUT
YOU'RE A SOUTH CAROLINA
GOVERNOR.
THERE WERE NO RULES FOR YOU
GUYS.
I MEAN THE LAST GOVERNOR TOOK
THE APPALACHIA TRAIL TO
ARGENTINA ON A MISSION FOR
SECRET POON
WHICH, BY THE WAY IS AGAINST
SOUTH CAROLINA LAW.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE DEBATE IS
ABOUT  ANYWAY.
IT'S NOT AN OFFICIAL FLAG.
IT'S A RELIC WITH NO PURPOSE
ANYMORE.
IT'S DECORATIVE.
YOU DON'T NEED A DECLARATION
TO REMOVE A DECORATION.
OKAY.
[
LOOK, IT'S TIME FOR A SEGMENT
WE CALL FOR THE RECORD.
FOR THE RECORD, THE
CONFEDERATE FLAG SENT A
TRADITIONAL OF HERITAGE.
IT'S INTIMIDATION.
THAT'S NOT MY OPINION.
THAT'S AN OBJECTIVE FACT.
ON MARCH 21st, 1861, THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CONFEDERACY,
STATED THAT THE CONFEDERATE
GOVERNMENT WAS BASED ON THE
GREAT TRUTH THAT THE NEGRO IS
NOT EQUAL TO THE WHITE MAN.
THAT SPEECH IS NOW CALLED THE
CORNER STONE SPEECH, BECAUSE
THAT IDEA IS THE CORNER STONE
OF THE CONFEDERACY.
YOU DON'T GET CLEARER THAN
THAT.
SOME PEOPLE SAY THAT SOUTHERN
STATES SHOULD FLY THE
CONFEDERATE FLAG BECAUSE OF
HERITAGE, BUT IF WE FLEW EVERY
FLAG FROM THE PAST, WHY NOT
FLY THE UNION JACK IN FRONT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE. AND FOR THE
RECORD, SOUTH CAROLINA,
YOU DON'T GET TO MAKE THE
HERITAGE ARGUMENT BECAUSE
THE STARS AND BARS HASN'T
BEEN IN PLACE SINCE THE CIVIL
WAR, IT WENT UP IN 1961 TO MARK
THE CENTENNIAL OF THE CIVIL WAR
COINCIDENTALLY WHEN THE BLACK
STARTED  WANTING CIVIL RIGHTS
1961, IT WAS A REMINDER TO
BLACK PEOPLE THAT THEY SHOULD
KNOW THEIR PLACE.
IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN USED AS A
SYMBOL OF INTIMIDATION AND
TERROR.
AND IN FACT, THE NEO NAZIS
OFTEN ADOPT THE CONFEDERATE
FLAG IN IT'S PLACE.
IT'S SUCH A RACIST SYMBOL THAT
IS DOES DOUBLE DUTY AS THE
BACKUP RACIST SYMBOL FOR
ANOTHER RACIST SYMBOL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IT'S CRAZY.
OKAY.
SO FOR THE RECORD, I GET IT
THAT PLENTY OF HONORABLE
PEOPLE HAVE FUZZY FEELINGS
ABOUT THE CONFEDERATE FLAG,
BUT THAT'S IRRELEVANT.
THEIR NOSTALGIA WILL NEVER
TRUMP THE PEOPLE WHO SEE IT AS
A SYMBOL OF HATE.
AND FOR A STATE TO FLY THIS
FLAG, THAT HATE IS THE MESSAGE
THEY SEND TO THEIR PEOPLE.
FOR THE RECORD, DOES THERE
REALLY NEED TO BE A DEBATE ON
WHETHER OR NOT TO YOU SHOULD
TAKE IT DOWN.
JUST DO IT. SERIOUSLY, TAKE IT
DOWN NOW.